HELLO EVERYBODY! :D
My name is Markiplier, and welcome to the Dishwasher Vampire Smile.
Now, weird name aside, this is actually a game
*breaths in*
that was brought BACK
* pause *
from -
* another long pause *
- the XBox 360 back in 2009.
Now, I'VE never played it before in my /life/,
but I actually have heard of it.
* begins reading text on screen *
I'm not gonna do a full playthrough of it, but I am gonna try this out for myself.
(Sure Mark.)
Because you play . . . as - I believe you're "Dishwasher",
and Dishwasher . . .
is a washer of dishes, I think?
* voice raising in pitch*
* reading screen again *
hEUH-HUH!
Whoa-
AND it's a very sMOOTH, like . . .
2D - platforming . . .
style, fighting, kill-em, beat-em-up, smash-em.
(Is that even correct grammar, Mark?)
St - Stutter
The developer of this game recently -
where am I?
oOOOOH MY GOD GIT REKT!!
hAUAUH-
Oh, I thought you were dead- * starts laughing *
hI-YAAAHH!
Well, you're tougher than I thought you'd be-
Oh, man-
Enemies aren't just, like . . . git GONE,
enemies are, like, TOUGH.
wHOA
hIYAH
Whoa, frick. * giggle *
A-HA-HA-HOWW!
STAHP IT!
HII-YAH!
uh-oh o-o
hA, GOD-
ooOOH
OH, I DID IT!
oH
hoOOOOOOOH
yEEAAHH
Oh, hi, okay
who are you? ; o ;
* dude falls over, he ded *
ooohhh
noooooh
* very confused Mark stance *
okAY, I had no idea I was gonna be doven into this
* pause * that bad-
* reads screen *
* puffle huffle  *
oKaY?
* reading screen again *
oH - SHIT
* screen reading *
okay?
I'm down!
(Okay Mark. You do you.)
oOkay-
oH, this is SO WEIRD! x2
Man, this threw me int-
this so quickly!
(Words, Mark.)
I have no idea! * Giggling *
hI-YAH-HA!
ooOOOH-
'KAAAAAY
HIIIII-IIII
oH, I'M CRAWLING NOW?
I've no idea what's happening, but I'm SO into it!
I AM SO 100% INTO THIS!
(You sure about that, Mark?)
HELLO?
Yes, please, thank you-
OH, I love the mix of 2D art and the- weird psycha-
like, psychedelic effects goin' on
aH, I CAN'T EVEN THINK OF THE WORDS TO DESCRIBE IT!
oh, man, okay, i'm-a
i'm trying to take this iN oH MY GOD-
I JUST GOT THAT WHEELCHAIR!
ooOOH
HIIII!
WHAT? O _ O
WHAT DID I DO?
oH NO
AM I A VAMPIRE?
DID I JUST STEP ON HIS BODY?? * Laughing *
WHY DID I DO THAT??
I mean, I guess it's okay, I-I guess- * shrug *
Hoh- Hi.
hE-EHH-
OH-HO-HO-OOHHH-
WHOA- GOD!
OH MAN!
* reading the screen *
oH
okAY
AAAAAAAHHH YOU GONNA SPARK FOR ME?
* disgusted/confused laughter *
heHHIYAAHH
Yer SPARKIN' on me!
OH-HO-HO FU-HU-HUCK
Oh my GAD, it's so COOL!
HOly SHITBALLS!
Oh ma- Oh my god (x3)
OH-HO-HO-HO FU-HU-HU-HU-HUCK-
OALRIGHT!
Oh, I got a hearts-
I got a-hearts goin' on from that.
Oh, it's so cool.
Whoa, hi! o 3 o
STOP THAT!
I think?
WHA-PBBPHT- WHAT HAPPENED??
I think I ripped his arm off, but you can barely thee thr- see through all the blood!
Oohh, YeeEEss! * laughing *
OH my GOD!
* raspberries? *
I dunno what I pulled outta him, but I think he needed it!
; )
AH!
BLAP- There goes his arms~
OP - Boop-a-doop!
* blaps *
Wait, hang on, I'm'onna grab you, you're tougher than this one.
NOT tHAT MUCH TOUGHER THO!
HUP- AND GO- oh you're dead, nevermind.
Got hearts tho. That's always nice. u w u
oH-HO-HO!
oH, that guy didn't even have a CHANCE!
Oh man, this is like One Finger Death Punch all over again!
Which I need to do another video of,
because I haven't done that in, like,
yEARS, and I used to play that just as a
regular stress reliever.
OH mah GAD!
aaAAH-HAH!
I'm SORRY!
oh fu- * starts laughing *
This is SO COOL!
Man, I gotta play their newwWWOAKAY?
OKAY!?
Alright then! I have a funny feeling that this would be easier to play on a- m-
a joystick or somethin' like that
but oH my GAD!
okay, ALRIGHT!
oKAY!
AALRIGHT THEN!
WHATEVER YOU SAY!
OKAY! ALRIGHT WHATEVER YOU SAY!
ooOoh, backtracking you say? Why is there . . .
Why is there so much TRAFFIC out there?
Holy crap, that's awesome.
I wish I knew what this world was aaaAAll about-
oOh boi
aaaAAHh-
what?
uuh-
yEEAAGH
WHAT WAS THAT??
Something about 'Showing you wonderful things!'
(And what are those things?)
I DUNNO!
You're turning into a vampire? o-o
oOOKAy, alright then "Yuki",
you go for it Yuki!
"You're defeated," "Submit."
NAAH I don't think so.
I'on't think so.
SHOOP- Oh, my go-ha.
THAT CAN'T FEEL GOOD!
That really can't feel good.
hAAH
Oh nao, you shot that guy- * giggles *
ohi
You guys look marginally better-
At this then-
-oh fuck, wELL not that much better, I guess.
hWOHA
WHAAAM-BAM
Missed me! xP
hWHOA- * starts laughing *
I'm just a kicking flurry as I pass over the floor here-
oh, oh-ho
HOP!
Good thing they got ninjas guarding this place.
WHY-WHY-WHY NINJAS?
I mean, yeah, I get it's cool stylistically-
Wh- Was that guy about to stab HIMSELF?
Why was he doin' that??
That was weird.
(Was it Mark?)
hAA-HAAA
Oh- * laughing *
OH, I did /marginally/ less good against those guys.
But, uh, we'll see about what else I can do about the rest of these assholes.
HOP-BOOOM!
OooOOAHH-
I did exactly what I shoulda done.
whOHA- What're you? o^o
wELL, NOT THAT THOUGH apparently!
BOOM!
BOOM!~ :D
OH-HO-HO-HO-HO!
YEAH, FLOATING SKULLS!
GET SHREKT YOU BADASSES!
OH my GAD, it's SO COOL!
AH, GA-GOT NOTHIN' ELSE TO SAY ABOUT IT-
oH FUUCK!
Alright, okay, enough a'that!
Jeez, the-the pil- (pilot? pile?) driving these exploding skulls.
Maybe they should fill these skulls with something OTHER than EXPLOSIVES!
Ah, jeez, where am I now?
oH
What am I-
what am I doin?
No?
That ain't right, okay, there's gotta be somethin' else up here.
oOoooOh, okay, I know what I gotta do, I gotta walk up this wall.
HA-DA-DA, apparently that's easy- * laughing *
Easy as that appare-wHOA GOD WHOA!
'Kay, alright, I can do that, I didn't know ab-bout that!
Man, what's gonna happen when I actually-
OOOH, YOU GET PILE DRIVE?
PILE DRIVED? Okay, thank you!
Wh- OW, OW! Don't do that!
Ga - Gotcha!
Apparently! GOTCHU ALSO!
Double combo on that one! >:3
Don't shoot me! (x2)
I'm unarmed!
You're about to be unarmed, but I'm even more unarmed!
HELLO!
* questioning the boss' name *
Arright, fine, whatever you say.
Alright, pssh, deal with the "Gay-ler" here.
He keeps dodgin' my grabs.
wHOA, hello!
BAAM! BAM, BAM, BAM! WHAAAAM!
oOOhh, not quite!
J- Mr. "Jailer-Gaoler."
HO-BO-BO-BO-BO! (x2)
* gibberish *
oH
OH!
OHH!
Where'd your head go??
Where the fuck'd your head go- whOA
Missed me! >:v
Man, you'd think that these guys would give up n' run away or somethin' because-
I am just wrecking up the b-
OH AND I GOT A SWORD NOW!
THAT'S LIKE A SWORD
I'M SUCH A BADASS! >:D
Oh my GOD! * weirded out laughing *
* more laughing *
I'm sorry, I needa-
needa stop freakin' out about everything I see.
OH, HA-BOINK!
H-How about a hA-BOINK
HA-BOINKIE YOU SAY?
OH HA-BOINK!
Man . . . they gotta get tougher robots.
I'd like to think those are just floating human heads in those things,
and they're actually just blowin' up in a horrible fashion.
oH NINJAS- Nah, you're just the guardsmen.
What're you gonna do to me? Apparently you're gonna do a lot because apparently you're fuckin' me up.
BLAP!
BOOP! And there ya go.
Now that was . . . spectacular!
HAA-BOH
BOP!
Ho my God!
You can definitely combo slicing them, tossing them up in the air.
Doin' all sorts a' stuff and then pile driving them into their destinies.
* victorious laughter *
They're sparkin' alright.
Ah man, I'm not even good at this!
I will readily admit I'm not good at this, but I FEEL powerful.
I feel more powerful than I would if I was playing "Devil Make Cry,"
or like . . . "God Of War," I feel UNBELIEVABLY power-
* interrupted by a boss *
WHO ARE YOU?
Alright!
Sure, let's go with that one.
HOP!
Ow- Okay, WHY? W- Right into that one I'm afraid to say.
Ah, okay, YOU PUNCH REAL! oOkaY!
AH!
Got somethin' there.
I got a hol- wHOA
One punch! Alright, let's try that again, I-I went off to a bad start.
I got- I kept runnin' into your po-unches!
Alright, come on. BRING IT ON AGAIN!
You know what this reminds me of in a little way?
The Al- The I- It almost reminds of "Alien Hobinant(?)," in a STRAGE way.
WHOA
HA-BA-BA-BA-BA
Okay, gotcha, oKAY yer not too hard!
Yer not too tough- oOH
* more gibberish *
Oh man, you-you regret everything, doncha? Oh.
OW! God those- Just the straight up JABS are bad for me.
OW, DON'TCHU DARE!
OH! You don't, YOU DON'T DARE! o ^ o
Cause you got NOTHIN- Oh my GOD!
OW!
WHAT THE HELL?! OW!
He cut off my arm!! o - o
WHY'D YOU DO THAT!?
oOkay!
Ooh, "Everything is clean here."
Why is everything clean here? o-o"
WHY is everything clean here? eue
Oh, okay, well, I mean, THE CLEAN CHAIR-
OOoohh, kayy I'm in an escape pod, apparently.
OOOHHH SHIIIITT-
ES-101-What-
everYTHING IS CLEAN HERE!
okay? ;v;
i'unno- ooohh, hi, alright, okay, that's a hallway
aND WHAT HAPPENED TO MY ARM?!
Well, I know what happened to my a- oOOH
HEY-HE-HE-HEY, HEEEEEY-HE NOW
HOW BOUT CHU STAY AWAY, I don't need that, okay, alright hello teeth! :3
How you doin'?
How you doin' there?
oOOooh good!
HOORAY!
I did pretty decent!
Not great, mind you, I'm not-
not one of the people who are really good that this, but I could see you getting REALLY good at this game.
And it being SO satisfying!
Like, this game was SO SATISFYING to play
It was so weird, how just AMAZINGLY * smack * TIGHT it felt!
AND IT JUST FELT SO BLOODY AND GOREY!
IN SUCH A SIMPLE PACKAGE! I LOVED IT
And it was so NOISY and GRUNGY and GRIM-DARK
I love it. : )
SO ANYWAY! That's all the time I got for this one, I don't plan on doing a full playthrough of this,
but maybe just as a stress reliever. I would love to play this again because THAT is FRICKEN COOL!
SO! THANK YOU SO MUCH everybody for watching, let me know what you think of this down in the comments below,
and I'll provide a link to it to Steam in the description as well.
Thanks again, and as always, I WILL SEE YOU! In the next video. BUH-BYEEE!